I'm thinking so spicy things first got
spicy in the 90s when we met Melanie C
in the Spice Girls and today she's even
spicier with her latest single blame it
on me more on Melanie's upcoming solo
album in a bit but first we had to take
a little trip down Spice Girls memory
lane
favorite Spice Girls song we did the
Olympics in London in 2012 we did spice
up your life and wannabe and we were on
top of these taxi cabs like going round
the stadium
singing spice up your life and from that
moment that became my favorite son is
there one song that you'd be fine if you
didn't have to perform it again I think
with the singles there's none of them I
couldn't because they are all so
precious but we did and the show's last
year we did a song called do it lads and
it's a really fun song
oh we just can't get the words wrong you
know you just get that mental block it's
like once you've done it wrong a few
times you're like I just can't get this
right
night once that song was done I was like
I'm so glad that's all the way what's
your favorite lyric Wow
favorite lyric oh we have some goodies
don't we
I think the ballads have some really
beautiful heartfelt lyrics you know to
become one was you know a beautiful
lyric and and again you know it was
subtle but it had a message me a little
bit wise a baby put it on put it on
[Music]
my personal is I want a man not a boy
who thinks he can that's a good one
[Music]
these music video that would have to be
too much it was like the lead song for
the movie and we were all in fact we all
shot separately and I think it was like
a 24 hour shoot with this I mean just
work so hard on that but we were all in
different like movies like a little bit
poltergeist it was all stop spinning
around the room and I was doing like
some kung fu movie and I was in my like
you know my lovely little outfit and
doing all my kicks again there she goes
again
with the martial arts but I am actually
interested in over space how many tracks
do you think you actually are oh my gosh
well back in the day I probably had
about a hundred and I think I'm not far
off at not know I think I've maybe got
maybe about thirty okay so the
collection have gotten smaller I made
the mistake of it I think a lot of it's
in storage but I made the mistake about
getting rid of all my stuff thinking
that's that's done now this is this is
the new grown-up for me and then like
90s fashion just like came back you were
the trend forecaster you knew that comfy
clothes were always the way to go
how crazy is that he's like now that my
daughter dresses like sporty spice and
I'm like and all her friends and I'm
like that's a look I created and she's
like whatever mom I mean does she know
how iconic you are I think she I was
cool when I was on stage at Wembley
Stadium with like 80,000 people
screaming at me but when I took her seat
ID her room I'm not yes mom
okay so maybe Melanie's 11 year old
daughter Scarlett plays it cool but the
rest of the world has got their fingers
and toes crossed for more Spice Girls
tours and maybe even new music you guys
crushed all the ticket sales and all the
records in the UK I have to ask is there
a chance the Spice Girls are going to
tour in the United States sometime soon
I hope so I really do we talk all the
time and we would love to do more shows
we really would I know that the world
has kind of been kind of been put on
hold at the moment but are there
conversations about upcoming spicy
projects there's always ongoing
conversations with us girls and you know
we're so proud of the legacy that we
have
there's a incredible generation of young
women and young guys that have grown up
you know living the Spice Girls and
feeling very inspired by them so we want
to just continue that you know we want
to we want to inspire future generations
and so that you know there's been talks
about animation there's been other
little things along the way but in all
honesty what I want to do is the shows
do the shows that's the big one for me
would it be a brand new tour or do you
think it would be sort of like the
celebration tour that you did in the UK
last summer creative that we had last
year with the show was perfect it was
nostalgic but it was modern it was a
real celebration of everything 90s and I
think we would obviously we definitely
like freshen up the show but I think the
essence of the show would have to remain
the same because it's just perfect for
us girls well I have to tell you you
know no one loves the the Spice Girls
catalog more than me but is there a
chance we would get new music from you
and the girls
do you guys ever write together or or
talk about releasing new music and it's
something that we have discussed and we
feel like you know we're nervous we have
such an incredible back catalogue and
people love our music you know you don't
want to produce anything that's not of
the standard if you're you know your
other work so you know we talk about a
tentatively and we're like you know what
we're not gonna force the issue on that
one we'd rather it happen organically do
you think there's a chance that you do
tour again as a group that Victoria
would join you that's something that you
guys have talked about always I mean we
were kind of hoping she'd end up come
and you know of course we respect her
ease and you know on her feelings
towards it and although she wasn't with
us on stage she was very much involved
in the show you know we wanted her to be
happy and comfortable with all of the
direction with the creative and
everything you know because it's her
baby as much as the rest of us you know
so yes so she was very much with us in
spirit even though she wasn't there
physically
yeah of course we do we took about two
overtime we we're always going online
maybe she will one day
you like call her out in a group chat
and be like babe can you come with us
like what's going on he's so funny cuz
like there's things she said what I
quite fun see that was holding her back
is we had a Spice Girls tour I think
that would certainly bring a lot of
levity and a lot of joy to these darker
times what is it gonna take
well you know maybe that is the thing
you know cause personally for me the way
I've been feeling it's like we know how
much sure the Spice Girls can bring to
so many people and you know I will be
you know doing everything I can within
my power to to try and get all of us
back onstage together for now Melanie is
gearing up to release her upcoming
eighth studio album the album not quite
ready to reveal it for a superfan this
would be interesting
all of my albums of being a song title
as the album title so I've always had a
song that I think really represents the
album and is the the title track this
time it's not a single it's not a song
title it's a the British powerhouse
singer tells et she drew inspiration for
her new tunes from her decades in the
iconic group I told you the Spice Girls
last year we did some shows in the UK
big stadium shows and it had been a
while since we could stage together so I
was nervous I was nervous at the thought
of becoming exporters focus again and
and whether I could actually do it and
quite quickly I realized I don't become
her I am her you know it's me and that
made me to start thinking about how I
wanted to customize myself moving
forward and I took all of those
wonderful experiences on stage and they
both got into this album so the first
single of who I am was really about
self-acceptance and you know accepting
accepting every part of yourself and
every aspect of your life and what
you've been through in and celebrating
do not only your successes but the tough
things that you've got through
you know I don't think we do that enough
and then blame it on me is a bit more I
think it's got a bit more swagger you
know it's one of those songs is about a
relationship it's about being really let
down by somebody it's like this toxic
relationship that someone is completely
like blindsided you when you find out
they're not who you put work
[Music]
how you are able to take something as
fun and light-hearted as a dance track
but actually put some pretty powerful
lyrics in there was it hard for you
writing this song you know is this is
this autobiographical talking about a
difficult relationship you were in yeah
you know I but I find that when I write
music it's always I find the best songs
are the ones that come from very true
emotions you know real experiences and
even though sometimes it can be a little
bit scary being you know opening
yourself up and being vulnerable that
it's also the most rewarding and I think
that people respond to that the best as
well because you know we're all human
yeah of course
and we got to talk about this video I
got to be completely honest I got major
Spice Girl vibes going back to the good
old days and the videos that you created
20-some odd years ago it was that
intentional completely intentional yeah
you know it's got this retro feel like
Kagame's in the 80s and 90s Street
Fighter and Mortal Kombat and I just
thought that is so fun but it made me
immediately think if say you'd be there
ah you remember that video we all had
our little characters so it was lovely
to incorporate that into the video get
Katrina high kick back out high kicking
and we thought it'd be really fun cuz
there's you know there's there's lots of
like text and little things pop up cause
it's like a bit of a video game fixed in
there and some songs and yeah yeah a
little her eggs all over it it was so
great with this forthcoming album I'm
curious what does this next chapter of
Melanie C look like I feel very excited
we know musically it's electronic it's
dance D but the lyrics are thoughtful
I've really kind of achieved what I set
up to do with this album and the other
thing working with the girls last year
we told the UK and Ireland or we had
fans from across the globe and it just
reminded me how much of an international
fan base is Spice Girls half you know
and so often the fans they save up all
their pennies they come to the UK they
come and see shows and I want to get to
them I want to get out there so as soon
as we can move and travel and perform
shows that's what I want to do that's
what this campaign looks
[Music]